was machte eintracht zu einem so
besonderen verbrecher man spricht ja
manchmal sogar von einem genie
das würde ich so nicht sagen es ist
wirklich ein besonderer verbrecher der
seit seiner kindheit bereits kontakte
mit der polizei hatte und nachdem mit 17
jahren sein hauptschulabschluss gemacht
hat nur noch durch kriminalität
versuchte sein leben so zu gestalten wie
er sich das vorgestellt hat tolle frauen
tolle autos tonne drogen usw so
intelligent war dass er wusste dass kann
ich niemals mit arbeit schaffen und so
ging es los mit auge aufbrüchen
autodiebstähle raubüberfällen
banküberfällen und so zeichnete er seine
heranwachsende zeit an und kam natürlich
auch ins gefängnis dort soll er immer
wieder gesagt habe ich werde irgendwann
einmal das große ding machen und dann
kann ich machen was ich will und er
scheint es ja auch einfach nicht lassen
zu können also selbst das gefängnis hält
ihn nicht davon ab weitere straftaten
dann immer wieder mehr freiheit zu
begehen wie wir gesehen haben aber
lassen sie uns noch einmal zurückgehen
wie haben sie damals von der reemtsma
entführung erfahren ja in der nacht zum
märz 1996 klingelte bei mir das telefon
ich war leiter des raubdezernates in
hamburg und für entführungen und
erpresserischen menschenraub zustände
mir wurde mitgeteilt dass der name
chinese jemand entführt worden sei und
es soll sich vermutlich um herrn riems
behandeln was bedeutet hast sofort aus
den betten ins präsidium gefahren die
ersten kollegen der dienstelle
benachrichtigt und man macht er an
beratern eine besprechung was geht los
das nächste wahl wer muss informiert
werden bei so eine person wie harings
mal ist eine information bis ganz nach
oben in der politik selbstverständlich
es war gut dass
die täter ja ihnen überfahren hatten als
er aus dem haus wohnhaus in seiner
arbeit auskennt und man hatte dort ein
zettel hinterlegt dass er entführt
worden ist dass man 20 millionen d mark
lösegeld haben wollte und dass die
polizei nicht alarmiert werden darf
weil sonst etwas angetan werden das
bedeutet also dass wir zunächst mal fern
halten mussten vor dem tatort den ich
dann mit einem anderen kollegen am
nächsten morgen konspirativ aufgesucht
habe um uns vor ort der ersten
erkenntnisse zu holen denn es war nicht
auszuschließen dass die täter die tat
beobachten und sehen ob polizeieinheiten
einfliegen
sagen sie uns was waren die größten
schwierigkeiten bei diesem fall und
vereinen die größten schwierigkeiten
ihnen dann letztendlich auf die schliche
zu kommen
ja das große problem war natürlich dass
zunächst die gefahrenabwehr im
vordergrund stehen es geht zunächst
darum das opfer nicht zu gefährden das
heißt wir konnten keine öffentlichen
ermittlungen anstellen sondern alles
musste unter der decke passieren weil
sonst die gefahr bestand davon riems mal
etwas passiert und ohne öffentlichkeit
kann man sehr schwer ermitteln also wir
mussten alles so machen dass es nicht an
die öffentlichkeit gelangte und dazu
muss man auch sagen dass die medien da
sehr gut mitgespielt haben keiner hat
etwas veröffentlicht was uns hätte
schaden können beziehungsweise vor dem
überhaupt nichts veröffentlicht so lange
lebensspanne freitag in vielen dank herr
und für diese einblicke jetzt nochmal
darin wie vor einem er selber herr
drache also für sich funktioniert jetzt
wird also den haftrichtern in amsterdam
dann vorgeführt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren